welcome to this special edition of
hannity the liberal policies failing
america i'm tammy bruce in for sean and
breaking tonight new travel restrictions
you guys from eight african countries to
the united states have been put into
place amid speculation about a new
coveted variant we will have full
coverage later in the show and also
ahead the devastating consequences of
left-wing crime policies are more
undeniable than ever we will show you
the tape but first tonight the ever
struggling joe biden is finding new and
creative ways to show just how out of
touch out of pocket and frankly out of
steam he really is
heading off to a billionaire's nan tuck
at home this week for the thanksgiving
holiday exposing once again his utter
disconnect from the middle class and
disconnect from common sense americans
all across the country and get this amid
slumping approval massive policy
failures and a never-ending stream of
baffling moments biden is still somehow
under the impression that quote america
is back take a look
oh hold on my phone's ringing justice oh
my god look at who's calling oh
hell hello
hello mr bro wow how you doing pal
oh dr biden and mr president thank you
so much happy thanksgiving to you how
are you firefighter
that's right we had a new york
firefighter here and it's so good
good for you calling we thank you so
much what's
what's your message to the american
folks on this thanksgiving day my
message is after two years you're back
america is back there's nothing we're
unable to overcome out
well there you go but of course the
destructive democrat agenda continues to
be dealt a brutal reality check
especially on the issue of surging
inflation for example just look at this
bizarre tweet from senator elizabeth
warren blaming businesses for rising
prices instead of her own party's
reckless policies tweeting quote
americans are paying record high prices
for their thanksgiving turkey while big
poultry companies are paying billions in
dividends giving ceos raises and earning
huge profits well that prompted a wave
of mockery from the left and right alike
and meanwhile u.s consumer optimism this
week hit a decade low and the wall
street fear index today yes we have one
hit its highest levels in 10 months
add that to the rising gas prices the
ongoing supply chain woes and get this
even a christmas tree shortage yeah
as the american christmas tree
association is warning that supply chain
issues and weather problems mean that
some trees will be in short supply so
tonight the biden harris agenda is
failing literally on every front
inflation is surging the border is still
a mess american adversaries are
emboldened all while democrats are still
eager to have us walk off a reckless far
left spending cliff
on their so-called build back better
agenda but ask yourself is there one
policy being pushed by the left that's
actually focused on improving the lives
of americans rolling back energy
independence means more pain at the gas
pump more cradle to grave entitlements
means more government dependence and
less optimism about finding work and
weak on crime policies are making
communities less and less safe and less
secure all across the country it of
course it's dangerous and it's
destructive but unfortunately all
business as usual for the extreme
democratic party